bienvenue dans cette série sur la compréhension de l'information et du calcul quantiques, je m'appelle John Watrous et je suis directeur technique de l'éducation chez IBM Quantum
c'est la 13e leçon de la série et la première leçon de la quatrième et dernière unité, qui porte sur l'erreur quantique
correction le calcul quantique a le potentiel de permettre des solutions efficaces à des tâches de calcul pour lesquelles
aucun algorithme classique efficace n'est connu, et peut-être n'existe pas il y a cependant des défis très importants que
il faudra surmonter si on veut implémenter ce genre de calculs quantiques à grande échelle que nous espérons un jour pouvoir
réaliser le cœur du problème est que l'information quantique est extrêmement fragile tu peux littéralement la ruiner juste en
la regardant et donc pour fonctionner correctement les ordinateurs quantiques doivent isoler l'information quantique qu'ils
stockent de l'environnement qui les entoure à un degré extrême mais en même temps l'ordinateur quantique lui-même doit nous fournir
un contrôle très précis sur cette information quantique, ce qui inclut une initialisation correcte, des opérations
unitaires précises et fiables et bien sûr la capacité d'effectuer des mesures pour pouvoir obtenir les résultats du
calcul il y a clairement une certaine tension entre ces exigences et aux débuts du calcul quantique certains estimaient que la fragilité
de l'information quantique et sa susceptibilité aux imprécisions et au bruit environnemental rendraient finalement
le calcul quantique impossible aujourd'hui il ne fait guère de doute que la construction d'un ordinateur quantique
à grande échelle précis et fiable est un défi monumental mais nous avons un outil clé pour nous aider dans cet effort, ce qui pousse la plupart
des personnes qui connaissent bien le domaine à être optimistes quant à la réalisation un jour du calcul quantique à grande échelle et cet outil c'est la correction d'erreur quantique
pour les quatre prochaines leçons nous allons discuter de la correction d'erreur quantique en nous concentrant sur les
fondamentaux dans cette leçon nous allons avoir un premier aperçu de la correction d'erreur quantique, notamment l'un des tout premiers codes quantiques
correcteurs d'erreurs découverts, le code de Shor à 9 qubit, et nous allons aussi discuter d'un autre concept fondamental en correction d'erreur quantique
connu sous le nom de discrétisation des erreurs dans les leçons suivantes de l'unité nous verrons des constructions de codes correcteurs d'erreurs quantiques plus sophistiquées et finalement meilleures
et nous allons aussi aborder le problème du calcul quantique sur de l'information quantique encodée en utilisant
des composants de calcul qui ne sont pas eux-mêmes parfaits et sont sujets aux erreurs voici un bref aperçu de la
leçon nous commencerons par discuter des codes de répétition classiques qui sont peut-être le type le plus simple et le plus basique
de code correcteur d'erreur classique les codes de répétition classiques ne sont pas des codes particulièrement bons selon les critères classiques
de la théorie du codage, du moins pas seuls mais ce n'est pas grave ici nous cherchons la simplicité et en particulier
nous allons examiner le code correcteur d'erreur classique le plus simple qu'on puisse imaginer, que nous utiliserons ensuite comme base pour un exemple simple
d'un code correcteur d'erreur quantique cet exemple est le code de Shor à 9 qubit que nous allons détailler
en incluant une description du code lui-même ainsi que des procédures pour encoder des qubit en utilisant ce code, détecter des erreurs sur des qubit encodés et
corriger ces erreurs et dans la troisième partie de la leçon nous allons discuter de la discrétisation des erreurs, ce qui nous permet de réfléchir aux erreurs arbitraires sur des
qubit qui forment en principe un continuum de possibilités en termes discrets, ramenant essentiellement les erreurs à
des retournements de bit et des retournements de phase avant d'entrer dans les détails techniques de la correction d'erreur quantique il
vaut la peine de prendre un moment pour réfléchir à la nécessité de la correction d'erreur quantique ainsi que de la correction d'erreur classique
comme je l'ai suggéré au début de la leçon les ordinateurs quantiques sont très susceptibles aux erreurs en raison de
la fragilité de l'information quantique en particulier les interactions indésirables avec l'environnement ou en
d'autres termes le reste du monde peuvent perturber l'information quantique ces interactions indésirables peuvent provoquer une décoherence où l'information
s'échappe essentiellement dans l'environnement, faisant que l'information stockée par l'ordinateur quantique se comporte de plus en plus
classiquement il est aussi d'une importance capitale de reconnaître que les opérations quantiques ne peuvent être effectuées qu'avec une précision limitée
par exemple nous pourrions souhaiter effectuer un gate quantique particulier sur un qubit mais parce que les dispositifs physiques ne sont
jamais parfaits ce que nous implémentons réellement pourrait n'être qu'une approximation de ce gate ce qui n'est peut-être pas grave pour un
seul gate mais si notre intention est d'effectuer des milliers ou des millions de gate quantiques ces petites imprécisions vont
commencer à s'accumuler et quand le calcul est terminé nous pourrions nous retrouver avec un état très différent de ce que nous
avions prévu c'est donc une source d'erreurs assez différente mais c'est certainement une que nous ne pouvons pas
ignorer les gens étudient les codes correcteurs d'erreurs classiques depuis près d'un siècle et ces codes ont de nombreuses applications notamment dans
la transmission et le stockage d'information mais parce que les composants de calcul classique sont si fiables nous n'avons pas vraiment
besoin de correction d'erreur pour construire des ordinateurs classiques il se pourrait maintenant que la correction d'erreur ne soit pas vraiment nécessaire
pour construire des ordinateurs quantiques à grande échelle fiables non plus par exemple l'idée principale derrière le calcul quantique topologique
est qu'il pourrait être possible de construire des systèmes quantiques robustes qui sont intrinsèquement protégés contre le bruit en raison
des propriétés topologiques des systèmes mais nous ne savons pas si cela sera possible et il est largement admis
que la correction d'erreur sera probablement essentielle sous une forme ou une autre pour le calcul quantique à grande échelle nous allons maintenant discuter des
codes de répétition classiques qui forment la base de notre premier code correcteur d'erreur quantique, le code de Shor à 9 qubit que
nous verrons bientôt les codes de répétition sont des exemples extrêmement basiques de codes correcteurs d'erreurs
l'idée est que nous pouvons protéger les bits contre les erreurs en répétant simplement chaque bit un certain nombre de fois en particulier jetons un coup d'œil à
le code de répétition à 3 bits ici nous encodons un bit en trois en répétant simplement le bit trois fois donc
zéro est encodé comme 000 et un est encodé comme 111 bien sûr si rien ne va de travers nous pouvons
facilement distinguer les deux possibilités mais s'il y avait une erreur et qu'un des bits a été retourné disons
ce qui signifie qu'un zéro devient un un ou qu'un un devient un zéro alors nous pouvons quand même déterminer quel était le bit d'origine
en voyant laquelle des deux valeurs binaires apparaît deux fois de façon équivalente nous pouvons décoder en calculant la valeur majoritaire
ou en d'autres termes la valeur binaire qui apparaît le plus fréquemment et il n'est pas difficile de voir que
si nous avons au maximum une erreur de retournement de bit alors le décodage sera correct bien sûr si deux bits sont retournés ou si
les trois bits sont retournés alors ça ne fonctionnera pas et nous obtiendrons la mauvaise valeur quand nous décodons et c'est une propriété générale
que tout code correcteur d'erreur possède tu peux peut-être corriger certaines erreurs mais tu ne pourras jamais corriger toutes les erreurs et finalement c'est
une question de diminuer les chances d'une erreur plutôt que de garantir l'exactitude ce qui n'est généralement pas
WEBVTT
possible prenons comme exemple une situation dans laquelle nous pouvons réduire les chances de faire une erreur supposons que notre
objectif est de communiquer un seul bit à un récepteur hypothétique et pour ce faire nous pouvons transmettre des bits à travers un
canal dit binaire symétrique qui retourne chaque bit envoyé à travers lui de façon indépendante avec une certaine probabilité
P donc avec une probabilité 1 moins P le récepteur recevra le bit que nous avions l'intention d'envoyer mais avec une probabilité P
le bit est retourné et le récepteur obtient la valeur opposée à ce que nous avons envoyé donc si nous n'utilisons pas le code de répétition
et qu'à la place nous envoyons simplement le bit que nous avons en tête à travers le canal le récepteur obtiendra le mauvais bit avec
une probabilité P d'un autre côté si nous encodons d'abord le bit que nous voulons envoyer en utilisant le code de répétition à 3 bits et
ensuite nous envoyons chacun des trois bits de l'encodage à travers le canal alors chacun d'eux est retourné avec une probabilité P donc
les chances d'un retournement de bit sont maintenant plus grandes parce qu'il y a maintenant trois bits qui pourraient potentiellement être retournés plutôt qu'un
mais si au maximum un des bits est retourné alors le récepteur pourra décoder correctement donc nous n'obtiendrons une erreur qu'après
le décodage si deux ou plusieurs des bits sont retournés lors de la transmission et il n'est pas trop difficile de calculer que cela se produit avec
une probabilité 3 * P ^2 - 2 * P Cub pour des valeurs de P inférieures à 1/ 12
cela conduit à une diminution de la probabilité que le récepteur se retrouve avec le mauvais bit il y aura encore une chance d'erreur dans ce cas mais le
code réduit la probabilité de cela et si tu voulais réduire encore plus les chances tu pourrais le faire en utilisant un
code différent y compris mais sans s'y limiter la possibilité d'utiliser un code de répétition où le bit encodé est répété
plus de trois fois pour des valeurs de P supérieures à 1/ 12 au fait le code rend
les choses pires dans le sens où il augmente la probabilité que le récepteur obtienne le mauvais bit donc nous n'utiliserions certainement pas ce code dans cette
situation le code de répétition à 3 bits est un code correcteur d'erreur classique mais nous pouvons aussi envisager ce qui se passe si nous
essayons de l'utiliser pour protéger des qubit contre les erreurs ce n'est pas un très bon code correcteur d'erreur quantique comme nous le verrons il
peut corriger certaines erreurs mais il rend d'autres erreurs plus probables c'est cependant la première étape vers le code de Shor
donc voyons comment cela fonctionne pour les qubit d'abord pour être clair quand nous faisons référence au code de répétition à 3 bits utilisé
pour des qubit ce que nous avons à l'esprit c'est un encodage d'un qubit comme montré à l'écran où Alpha 0 plus beta 1 est
encodé comme Alpha 0000 0 plus beta 111 ou en d'autres termes l'état de base standard
est répété trois fois remarque en particulier que ce n'est pas la même chose que de répéter l'état quantique trois fois comme dans un
état quantique s encodé comme s tenseur s tenseur s ce qui n'est pas un encodage que nous serions capables de
mettre en œuvre pour un état quantique inconnu s à cause du théorème de non-clonage l'encodage dont nous parlons
d'un autre côté est très facilement implémenté voici un circuit quantique très simple qui le fait en utilisant deux qubit de travail initialisés et deux
gate à not contrôlé maintenant supposons qu'une erreur se produit après que l'encodage a été
effectué et en particulier supposons qu'une opération poly X ou en d'autres termes un retournement de bit se produit sur l'un des
qubit et dans cette figure c'est le qubit du milieu bien sûr ce n'est pas le seul type d'erreur qui pourrait se produire et tu pourrais
t'opposer à l'idée qu'une erreur prend la forme de cette opération unitaire parfaite mais nous reviendrons là-dessus plus tard dans la leçon et pour l'instant nous pouvons
juste y penser comme un exemple voici l'état résultant il est identique à l'encodage original sauf
que le bit du milieu dans chaque K a été retourné évidemment nous pouvons le voir à partir des expressions mathématiques pour l'état
mais supposons que nous avions seulement les trois qubit et que nous soupçonnions qu'un retournement de bit aurait pu se produire mais que nous ne savions pas quel qubit aurait pu être
affecté une façon de déterminer si un retournement de bit s'est produit serait d'effectuer une mesure dans la base standard et d'examiner le résultat dans ce cas nous verrions
soit 010 soit 110 avec des probabilités dépendant de Alpha et beta et dans les deux cas notre conclusion
serait que le bit du milieu a été retourné mais malheureusement cela ruine l'état quantique original et cet état
pourrait nous être précieux après tout le but entier est de protéger cet état quantique donc ce n'est pas une bonne
option ce que nous pouvons faire à la place c'est d'utiliser le circuit quantique montré ici à l'écran où nous faisons entrer l'état encodé
dans les trois qubit du haut essentiellement ce que fait le circuit c'est de calculer la parité des
états de base standard pour les deux qubit du haut ainsi que pour les deux qubit du bas de l'encodage et cela révélera
l'emplacement du retournement de bit en particulier dans ce cas nous obtiendrons le résultat un pour ces deux vérifications de parité et à partir de
ces informations nous pouvons conclure que c'est le bit du milieu qui est différent des deux autres donc c'est évidemment celui qui
a été retourné et cruciale ment cela ne provoque pas l'effondrement de l'état donc nous avons maintenant une chance d'essayer de corriger ce retournement de
bit pour qu'éventuellement nous puissions peut-être décoder et récupérer notre état original nous reviendrons à la correction
dans un instant mais voyons d'abord brièvement les autres possibilités pour une erreur de retournement de bit si à la place l'erreur de retournement de bit
s'est produite sur le qubit du bas ou de gauche alors nous obtiendrons le résultat un zéro en lisant de bas en haut et encore
l'état ne changerait pas et si le retournement de bit s'est produit sur le qubit du haut alors le résultat serait
01 et encore une fois l'état ne change pas et au fait si il n'y avait pas eu
d'erreur de retournement de bit du tout alors le résultat de mesure est 00 et encore une fois l'état sort inchangé
résumons tout cela sous forme de tableau où nous listons chacun des états possibles que nous obtenons avec au plus un retournement de bit la mesure
résultats que nous appelons le syndrome dans le contexte de la correction d'erreur et la correction que nous devons effectuer pour obtenir l'encodage original
s'il n'y avait pas d'erreur le syndrome est zéro zéro et rien n'a besoin d'être fait pour corriger
l'état si le qubit du bas ou de gauche a subi un retournement de bit le syndrome est un zéro et la correction appropriée
est d'appliquer un gate X au qubit du bas ou de gauche et les deux autres cas sont
similaires donc si nous appliquons la correction appropriée basée sur le syndrome alors nous sommes certains de récupérer l'encodage original
dans les quatre cas encore une fois nous ne considérons que la possibilité qu'au plus un retournement de
bit se soit produit cela ne fonctionnerait pas correctement si deux ou trois bits ont été retournés et nous n'avons pas non plus envisagé la
possibilité d'autres erreurs considérons maintenant un type différent d'erreur dans le contexte quantique les erreurs de retournement de
bit ne sont pas les seules erreurs dont nous devons nous préoccuper par exemple nous devons aussi nous inquiéter des erreurs de retournement de
phase ou simplement des retournements de phase en abrégé qui sont décrits par des gate Z ou de façon équivalente des poly Z
WEBVTT
opérations malheureusement le code de répétition à 3 bits échoue complètement à détecter les retournements de phase par exemple supposons que nous
encodions un qubit en utilisant le code de répétition à 3 bits comme avant et qu'une erreur de retournement de phase se produise sur le qubit du
milieu nous obtiendrons l'état montré à l'écran qui est exactement l'encodage que nous aurions obtenu si un
retournement de phase s'était produit sur le qubit original avant que nous encodions et donc si nous effectuons le même
circuit qu'avant pour essayer de détecter une erreur nous obtiendrions le syndrome z0 ce qui suggère à tort qu'aucune erreur ne s'est produite
donc le code de répétition à 3 bits fonctionne pour au maximum un retournement de bit mais il échoue à détecter les erreurs de retournement de phase
en fait il aggrave les choses dans un certain sens car nous avons maintenant trois fois plus de qubit qui pourraient potentiellement subir un retournement de
phase nous avons observé que le code de répétition à 3 bits est complètement aveugle aux erreurs de retournement de phase donc il ne semble pas
être très utile pour traiter ce type d'erreur mais en fait nous pouvons modifier le code de répétition à 3 bits pour qu'il
détecte les erreurs de retournement de phase et je vais maintenant expliquer comment cela peut être fait voici le circuit original pour
encoder un qubit en utilisant le code de répétition à 3 bits et la façon dont nous allons le modifier est très simple nous appliquons juste un
gate Hadamard à chaque qubit de l'encodage un gate Hadamard transforme un état zéro en un état plus et un
état un en un état moins donc l'effet net est que nous obtenons l'état montré à l'écran où ket
Plus+ plus et ket minus- minus sont des notations abrégées pour le tenseur de trois états plus ou de trois états moins
une erreur de retournement de phase ou en d'autres termes un gate Z transforme les états plus en états moins et les états moins en
états plus donc cet encodage sera utile pour détecter et corriger les erreurs de retournement de phase et pour faire cela nous pouvons
modifier le circuit de détection d'erreur comme avant de la façon suivante voici le circuit d'avant et ce que nous allons faire c'est
simplement d'ajouter des gate Hadamard au début et à la fin comme montré à l'écran
l'idée est très simple les trois premiers gate Hadamard transforment les états plus et moins en états zéro et un les
mêmes vérifications de parité qu'avant ont lieu et ensuite la deuxième couche de gate Hadamard nous ramène à notre
encodage une autre façon de penser à cela est que nous transformons essentiellement les erreurs de retournement de phase en erreurs de retournement de bit par conjugaison par des opérations Hadamard
nous pouvons d'ailleurs simplifier le circuit un peu ce circuit ici est complètement équivalent
et tu peux vérifier cela toi-même si tu en as envie donc si nous mettons notre qubit encodé dans ce circuit en supposant
qu'aucune erreur de retournement de phase ne s'est produite nous obtenons le syndrome 00 indiquant qu'il n'y avait pas d'erreurs de retournement de phase
et si nous avons une erreur de retournement de phase sur le qubit du haut disons alors les plus et les moins les plus à droite basculent
et cela donne un syndrome d'erreur différent 01 dans ce cas qui identifie l'emplacement du retournement de phase tout comme
nous avions pour le retournement de bit et nous pouvons ensuite le corriger en appliquant un gate Z au qubit du haut et la situation
est similaire pour les erreurs de retournement de phase sur l'un des deux autres qubit donc nous pouvons en fait détecter et
corriger jusqu'à une erreur de retournement de phase en utilisant ce code mais malheureusement comme tu l'as peut-être deviné nous ne pouvons plus
corriger les erreurs de retournement de bit tout n'est pas perdu cependant car nous pouvons en fait combiner ces deux codes
ensemble pour obtenir un code qui peut corriger à la fois les erreurs de retournement de bit et de retournement de phase et en fait il sera capable de
corriger toute erreur sur un seul qubit il est maintenant temps de discuter du code de Shor à 9 qubit qui est un code quantique
correcteur d'erreurs que nous pouvons obtenir en combinant ensemble les deux codes que nous venons de voir, c'est-à-dire le code de répétition à 3 bits
qui nous permet de corriger une seule erreur de retournement de bit et la version modifiée de ce code qui nous permet de corriger un seul retournement de phase
pour être plus précis le code de Shor à 9 qubit est le code que nous obtenons en concaténant les deux codes ce qui signifie
que nous appliquons d'abord un encodage qui encode un qubit en trois puis nous appliquons l'autre encodage à chacun des
trois qubit séparément donc nous obtiendrons neuf qubit au total nous pouvons exprimer cela sous la forme
d'un diagramme de circuit comme suit d'abord nous allons appliquer la version modifiée du code de répétition à 3 bits
qui détecte les erreurs de retournement de phase et ensuite nous encodons chacun des qubit résultants indépendamment en utilisant le code de répétition à 3 bits original
donc si nous réduisons un peu ce circuit pour faire un peu plus de place nous pouvons
spécifier le code en termes un peu différents en décrivant comment les deux états de base standard pour notre qubit original sont
encodés et une fois que nous savons cela nous pouvons déterminer par linéarité comment un vecteur d'état de qubit arbitraire est
encodé donc voilà le code de Shor à 9 qubit et l'idée est que l'un des codes nous permet de corriger les erreurs de retournement de phase
et l'autre code nous permet de corriger les erreurs de retournement de bit et comme nous le verrons cela impliquera en fait que nous pouvons
corriger une erreur arbitraire sur un seul qubit voyons maintenant comment nous pouvons détecter et corriger des erreurs en utilisant le code de Shor à 9 qubit
en commençant par les erreurs de retournement de bit qui sont aussi appelées erreurs X voici le circuit qui effectue
l'encodage et juste pour faciliter la discussion nous allons penser aux neuf qubit que nous obtenons de ce code comme étant
regroupés en trois blocs de trois qubit où chaque bloc représente l'encodage que nous obtenons en appliquant
la deuxième étape d'encodage qui est le code de répétition ordinaire à 3 bits c'est ce qu'on appelle le code interne dans
ce contexte alors que le code externe est le code utilisé pour la première étape d'encodage qui dans ce cas est la version modifiée
du code de répétition à 3 bits qui fonctionne pour les erreurs de retournement de phase pour corriger les erreurs de retournement de bit nous pouvons
simplement traiter chacun des blocs séparément chaque bloc est un encodage d'un qubit en utilisant le code de répétition à 3 bits
et ce code protège contre les erreurs de retournement de bit supposons d'abord qu'une erreur X se produit sur l'un des qubit
comme le qubit du milieu dans le bloc du milieu si nous vérifions indépendamment chacun des blocs pour les erreurs de retournement de bit et
que nous corrigeons les erreurs que nous trouvons alors cette erreur sera corrigée et l'encodage original sera
récupéré en fait nous pourrions même avoir plusieurs erreurs X et les corriger de cette façon à condition que les erreurs soient
dans des blocs séparés si nous avions deux ou trois erreurs X dans un seul bloc nous aurions des problèmes mais
tant qu'il y a au maximum une erreur X par bloc le code interne les détectera et nous pourrons récupérer l'état encodé original
donc corriger les erreurs de retournement de bit est assez simple pour ce code nous devons aussi prendre en compte les erreurs de retournement de phase
ou en d'autres termes les erreurs Z cette fois ce n'est pas aussi clair de ce que nous devrions faire parce que le code externe est celui
qui corrige les erreurs de retournement de phase mais nous ne pouvons pas les détecter et les corriger directement parce que le code interne est en quelque sorte
WEBVTT
dans le chemin mais nous verrons comment faire cela bientôt pour mieux comprendre comment les erreurs X et Z
fonctionnent et les effets qu'elles ont dans les circuit quantiques il est utile d'observer quelques relations simples entre ces erreurs et les gate C
not et cela sera aussi utile dans une leçon ultérieure commençons d'abord par les erreurs X
ou les gate X et comment ils se rapportent aux gate C not si nous appliquons un gate X au
qubit cible d'un C not et ensuite appliquons le C not alors c'est équivalent à échanger l'ordre et faire le C not
d'abord d'un autre côté si nous appliquons un gate X au qubit de contrôle d'un C not et ensuite appliquons le C not nous ne pouvons pas simplement
échanger l'ordre mais à la place nous devons appliquer le gate X aux deux qubit et tu peux vérifier toutes ces relations
toi-même si tu le souhaites en réfléchissant à ce qui se passe avec les états de base standard par exemple la situation est similaire pour les erreurs Z
sauf que les rôles des qubit de contrôle et cible s'inversent en particulier si nous effectuons un
gate Z sur le qubit de contrôle d'un C not et ensuite effectuons le C not alors cela a le même effet que d'effectuer le
gate Z après le C not mais si nous effectuons le gate Z sur le qubit cible à la place alors c'est
équivalent à d'abord effectuer le C not et ensuite appliquer un gate Z aux deux qubit et finalement toutes ces
relations sont symétriques dans le sens où nous pouvons toujours échanger l'ordre des gate des deux côtés de chaque équation
ce qui est équivalent à prendre l'inverse ou le transposé conjugué des deux côtés étant donné que X Z et C not
les gate sont tous leurs propres inverses maintenant considérons les erreurs de retournement de phase et comment nous pouvons les détecter et les corriger
en utilisant le code de Shor à 9 qubit voici notre circuit d'encodage et nous allons continuer à penser aux neuf
qubit utilisés dans l'encodage comme étant regroupés en trois blocs de trois qubit supposons qu'une erreur Z se produit sur
l'un des qubit comme celui indiqué ici en utilisant ce que nous venons d'observer sur les gate Z
et les gate C not c'est équivalent à deux erreurs Z avant le C not l'une sur le
qubit de contrôle et l'une sur le qubit cible et ces erreurs se trouvent commuter avec l'autre C not du bloc donc nous
pouvons échanger l'ordre et voici ce que nous obtenons l'erreur Z inférieure ne fait rien parce qu'elle agit sur un état
zéro et nous pouvons tout glisser et obtenir ce diagramme donc ce que nous avons trouvé c'est qu'une erreur Z quelque part dans
le bloc du milieu est équivalente à une erreur Z se produisant sur le qubit du milieu avant la deuxième phase d'encodage et
tu peux raisonner exactement de la même façon pour une erreur Z sur l'un des qubit un retournement de phase sur n'importe quel qubit dans un bloc
est équivalent à un retournement de phase sur le qubit correspondant avant l'encodage interne et c'est en fait assez simple et intuitif si tu
réfléchis à la façon dont les erreurs Z affectent le code de répétition à 3 bits donc une option pour traiter une erreur Z
est de décoder le code interne puis de détecter et corriger les erreurs Z en utilisant le code externe qui est la version modifiée
du code de répétition à 3 bits qui peut corriger une erreur Z donc cela corrige notre erreur Z et
nous pourrions ré-encoder avec le code interne si nous le souhaitons nous pouvons aussi corriger les erreurs Z
en place pour ainsi dire sans décoder et puis ré-encoder et c'est assez simple mais pour expliquer comment nous
pouvons faire cela nous aurons besoin d'un peu plus d'espace supposons que nous décodions le code interne
et ensuite nous calculons le syndrome pour le code externe en utilisant la même méthode qu'avant où nous impliquons seulement les trois qubit du code externe et
ensuite nous ré-encodons eh bien nous pouvons simplifier tous ces C not un peu et en fait
nous pouvons utiliser les relations entre les gate not et les gate C not que nous venons d'observer il y a quelques instants pour nous aider dans cette
tâche et en faisant cela nous pouvons économiser quatre C not et voici le circuit que nous obtenons si une erreur Z s'est produite sur l'un des
qubit ce que le syndrome nous dit maintenant ce n'est pas quel qubit a subi une erreur Z mais plutôt dans quel bloc l'erreur Z
s'est produite mais ce n'est pas grave parce que nous savons que peu importe quel qubit dans un bloc subit une erreur Z l'effet
est le même pour les trois qubit dans ce bloc et donc nous pouvons en fait corriger l'erreur Z en appliquant un gate Z à n'importe lequel des
qubit dans ce bloc c'est d'ailleurs un exemple de ce qu'on appelle la dégénérescence dans un code
correcteur d'erreurs où nous n'identifions pas de façon unique une erreur donnée mais nous sommes capables de la corriger quand même supposons finalement que les deux
un retournement de bit et un retournement de phase se produisent éventuellement sur le même qubit par exemple supposons qu'un
retournement de bit et un retournement de phase se produisent sur ce qubit ici il s'avère que ces erreurs peuvent être
détectées et corrigées complètement indépendamment et en fait peu importe si nous corrigeons chaque bloc pour un
retournement de bit d'abord puis corrigeons pour les retournements de phase ou si nous le faisons dans l'autre sens pour voir cela observons d'abord
que l'ordre de ces erreurs n'a pas d'importance donc nous pouvons les inverser si nous le souhaitons la raison pour cela n'est pas que
X et Z commutent parce qu'ils ne commutent pas X * Z est égal à moins Z * X mais le
facteur moins 1 n'a aucun effet dans cette situation parce que c'est une phase globale nous pouvons maintenant déplacer l'erreur Z tout comme
avant et à ce stade il est évident que si nous corrigions d'abord chaque bloc pour les erreurs X et ensuite nous corrigions
les erreurs Z nous aurions alors corrigé les deux erreurs sinon si pour une raison quelconque
nous décidions de corriger d'abord les erreurs Z nous pourrions le faire et l'erreur X n'a absolument aucun effet dans ce processus
cela doit être vrai parce que premièrement l'erreur X commute avec chaque gate du circuit qui calcule le
syndrome pour le code externe et deuxièmement l'ordre entre l'erreur X et le gate Z que nous appliquons pour effectuer la
correction n'a pas d'importance tout comme nous avions argumenté quand le gate Z était une erreur donc cela permet la correction de l'erreur Z
et nous pouvons ensuite corriger chaque bloc pour éliminer l'erreur X donc ce que nous avons argumenté c'est que nous
pouvons corriger une erreur X une erreur Z ou les deux sur n'importe lequel des qubit en utilisant ce code
en fait nous pouvons corriger plus d'erreurs que cela comme plusieurs erreurs X tant qu'elles tombent dans des blocs différents
ou plusieurs erreurs Z tant qu'au plus un bloc en reçoit un nombre impair mais pour la suite ce qui sera le plus pertinent
c'est que nous pouvons corriger une erreur X une erreur Z ou les deux sur n'importe quel qubit et dans la dernière partie de la leçon
nous verrons comment cela suffit en fait pour conclure que ce code peut corriger une erreur arbitraire sur n'importe quel
qubit avant de passer à la dernière partie de la leçon dans laquelle nous allons envisager des erreurs quantiques arbitraires nous allons brièvement
envisager la performance du code de Shor à N qubit quand des erreurs représentées par des matrices de Pauli se produisent aléatoirement sur les
WEBVTT
qubit pour être plus concret considérons un modèle de bruit simple où les erreurs se produisent indépendamment sur les qubit
avec chaque qubit subissant une erreur avec une probabilité p et sans corrélation entre les erreurs sur différents
qubit le pire cas pour le code de Shor à 9 qubit est qu'une erreur Y ou en d'autres termes à la fois une erreur X et une erreur Z
se produit sur chaque qubit affecté et nous allons supposer ce scénario du pire cas juste pour obtenir une borne
sur la performance du code mais tu pourrais aussi envisager par exemple que les trois erreurs de Pauli sont également
probables maintenant supposons que Q est un qubit dans un état particulier que nous aimerions protéger contre les erreurs et imagine que
nous avons la possibilité d'utiliser le code de Shor à 9 qubit devrait-on l'utiliser eh bien la réponse n'est pas nécessairement
oui parce que s'il y a trop de bruit ou en d'autres termes si p est trop grand utiliser le code de Shor pourrait en fait aggraver les choses
tout comme nous avions pour le code de répétition quand p est supérieur à 1/2 mais si p est suffisamment petit alors la
réponse est oui nous devrions utiliser le code voyons donc pourquoi c'est le cas et ce que cela signifie que p soit trop grand ou suffisamment
petit pour ce code le code de Shor peut corriger toute erreur de Pauli sur un seul qubit et dans le pire
cas où les erreurs de Pauli sont des erreurs Y cela signifie que le code protège avec succès Q avec une probabilité donnée par
l'expression montrée à l'écran plus précisément le code fonctionne quand il n'y a aucune erreur et cela se produit
avec une probabilité 1 moins p ^ 9 parce qu'il y a neuf qubit qui doivent chacun être non affectés et cela fonctionne quand il y a
exactement une erreur et étant donné qu'il y a neuf qubit différents qui pourraient potentiellement être affectés cela se produit avec une probabilité 9 * P * 1 - p ^ 8
d'un autre côté si nous ne prenions pas la peine d'utiliser le code notre seul et unique qubit serait non affecté par une erreur avec
une probabilité 1 moins P donc le code ne sert que quand la première probabilité est supérieure à la seconde
parce que ces expressions représentent nos probabilités de succès dans les deux cas quand nous utilisons le code et quand nous
ne l'utilisons pas voici un graphe de ces deux fonctions pour de petites valeurs de p et nous trouvons que le point d'équilibre se situe à
environ 3 et 3/4 pour cent donc si p est inférieur à cette valeur alors le code
aide au point d'équilibre les probabilités sont égales donc nous gaspillons juste notre temps ainsi que 8 qubit si
nous utilisons le code mais sinon il n'y a pas d'inconvénient et au-delà de ce point nous ne devrions absolument pas utiliser ce code
parce qu'il augmente en fait les chances d'une erreur sur le qubit encodé que nous appelons généralement le
qubit logique dans ce contexte et cela se produit simplement parce que les chances de deux erreurs ou plus sur neuf qubit sont
supérieures aux chances d'une erreur sur un seul qubit pour des valeurs de p dans cette plage 3 et 3/4% peut ne pas sembler très
bon notamment par rapport à 50% qui est le point d'équilibre analogue pour le code de répétition à 3 bits pour
l'information classique mais il est plus difficile de protéger l'information quantique et de plus bien que ce
code représente une découverte brillante en tant que tout premier code correcteur d'erreur quantique et qu'il se trouve être excellent à des fins pédagogiques le fait est
qu'il n'est pas très bon en termes pratiques jusqu'à présent nous avons considéré les erreurs X
et les erreurs Z dans le contexte du code de Shor à 9 qubit considérons maintenant des erreurs arbitraires
en commençant d'abord par les erreurs unitaires par exemple une telle erreur pourrait correspondre à une très petite
rotation de la sphère de Bloch représentant peut-être une erreur causée par un gate qui n'est pas parfait par exemple
ou cela pourrait être toute autre opération unitaire sur un qubit et pas nécessairement quelque chose de proche de l'identité
opération il peut sembler difficile de corriger de telles erreurs il y a une infinité d'erreurs possibles comme
cela et il est inconcevable que nous puissions identifier exactement quelle est l'erreur et ensuite l'annuler mais nous
n'avons pas besoin de faire quoi que ce soit de différent de ce que nous avons déjà discuté tant que nous pouvons corriger un retournement de bit un retournement de phase ou les deux alors nous
allons en fait réussir à corriger une erreur unitaire arbitraire sur un seul qubit et je vais maintenant expliquer pourquoi
premièrement comme toutes les matrices 2x2 nous pouvons exprimer une matrice unitaire arbitraire
représentant une erreur sur un seul qubit comme une combinaison linéaire des quatre matrices de Pauli incluant la matrice
identité et au fait comme tu l'as peut-être remarqué j'utilise les majuscules X Y et Z pour désigner les matrices de Pauli non-identité
et je continuerai à faire cela pour le reste de cette série c'est conventionnel en correction d'erreur quantique et cela rend aussi
les choses un peu plus faciles à lire dans ce contexte il sera aussi pratique d'utiliser des indices pour indiquer sur lequel
qubit une opération unitaire donnée sur un qubit agit donc par exemple si nous utilisons la convention de numérotation des qubit de Qiskit
en commençant par le qubit zéro à droite alors nous avons les expressions montrées à l'écran pour
diverses opérations unitaires sur des qubit uniques où dans chaque cas nous faisons le produit tensoriel de la matrice unitaire avec la matrice identité
sur chaque autre qubit donc en particulier nous pouvons exprimer UK c'est-à-dire U appliqué au qubit K comme la même
combinaison linéaire qu'avant sauf que chaque matrice de Pauli est appliquée au qubit K nous n'avons pas besoin de s'embêter avec le
sous-indice pour l'identité soit dit en passant l'idée ici est que c'est l'identité sur tous les
qubit supposons maintenant que sII est l'encodage à 9 qubit d'un état de qubit si l'erreur U se produit sur le
qubit k alors nous obtenons u k * s que nous pouvons exprimer comme une combinaison linéaire d'opérations de Pauli agissant sur S ce qui bien sûr
est juste s dans le cas de l'identité à ce stade il va être utile d'observer que la matrice de Pauli Y
est égale à i * X * Z donc nous pouvons effectuer cette substitution dans notre
expression donc cette erreur a eu lieu et supposons maintenant que nous essayons de la corriger en utilisant la même procédure que
pour la première étape consiste à calculer le syndrome qui dans le cas du code de Shor fait 8 bits de long deux bits pour chacune des
trois fois où nous utilisons le code interne ainsi que deux bits supplémentaires pour le code externe mais peu importe nous pouvons juste y penser comme
une chaîne de longueur fixe voici une description de l'état que nous obtenons juste avant la mesure du syndrome où chaque
syndrome correspond aux huit bits que nous obtenons de l'erreur de Pauli correspondante remarque à ce stade que les deux
systèmes sont corrélés en général et vraiment c'est la clé pour que tout cela fonctionne en mesurant le syndrome ce que
nous faisons effectivement c'est effondrer l'état en un état où l'une des quatre opérations de Pauli a été appliquée au
qubit Ki de sII et nous saurons d'après le syndrome quelle opération de Pauli c'était donc nous pouvons la corriger si
nécessaire en particulier si nous mesurons le syndrome et effectuons la correction appropriée alors nous obtenons un état de
WEBVTT
la forme montrée à l'écran qui de façon critique est un état produit nous avons notre encodage original non corrompu comme
facteur tenseur de droite ce qui est le plus important ici et à gauche nous avons une matrice densité s qui
décrit un syndrome d'erreur aléatoire mais il n'y a plus de corrélation avec le système qui nous intéresse qui est
celui de droite parce que les erreurs ont été corrigées à ce stade nous pouvons jeter les qubit du syndrome ou les réinitialiser
si nous voulons les réutiliser et c'est en fait assez important parce que c'est ainsi que l'aléatoire ou l'entropie
générés par les erreurs est retirée du système et c'est ainsi que fonctionne la discrétisation des erreurs du moins pour les erreurs unitaires
en essence en mesurant le syndrome nous projetons effectivement l'erreur sur une erreur décrite par
une matrice de Pauli à première vue cela peut sembler trop beau pour être vrai que nous puissions corriger des erreurs unitaires arbitraires
comme cela même des erreurs qui sont minuscules et à peine remarquables en elles-mêmes mais ce qu'il est important de réaliser ici
c'est que c'est une erreur unitaire sur un seul qubit et par la conception du code une opération sur un seul qubit ne peut pas changer l'état
du qubit logique qui est encodé tout ce qu'elle peut faire c'est déplacer l'état hors de l'espace des encodages valides
mais ensuite les corrections le ramènent exactement là où il était finalement considérons ce qui se passe
quand une erreur arbitraire pas nécessairement unitaire se produit la configuration est la même qu'avant
nous avons encodé un qubit en 9 en utilisant le code de Shor et une erreur arbitraire représentée par un canal de qubit thi
se produit sur l'un des qubit comme nous allons le voir tout va se passer à peu près de la même façon
que pour les erreurs unitaires et la première étape pour vérifier cela est de considérer une représentation de Kraus de notre
erreur ce que nous pouvons faire maintenant c'est suivre exactement le même raisonnement que pour les erreurs unitaires sauf que nous appliquons ce
raisonnement aux matrices de Kraus plutôt qu'à une seule matrice unitaire représentant une erreur
en particulier chaque matrice de Kraus peut être exprimée comme une combinaison linéaire de matrices de Pauli et cela nous permet de
exprimer l'action de cette erreur fi sur quel que soit le qubit K sur lequel elle se produit sous la forme montrée ici à l'
écran tout ce que nous faisons vraiment ici c'est développer les matrices de Kraus comme des combinaisons linéaires de matrices de Pauli
matrices si nous calculons et mesurons ensuite le syndrome d'erreur et corrigeons les erreurs révélées nous obtiendrons un
état similaire à ce que nous avions dans le cas d'une erreur unitaire je ne vais pas entrer dans les détails c'est tout à fait similaire au cas unitaire
et aussi un peu plus compliqué à écrire mais conceptuellement parlant c'est assez
simple je dois mentionner que tout cela se généralise à d'autres codes correcteurs d'erreurs quantiques y compris les codes qui peuvent corriger des erreurs sur plusieurs
qubit dans un tel cas les erreurs sur plusieurs qubit peuvent être exprimées comme des combinaisons linéaires de produits tensoriels de matrices de Pauli
matrices et en conséquence les différents syndromes possibles décriront des corrections effectuées sur plusieurs qubit plutôt que sur un seul
qubit mais l'idée sous-jacente est exactement la même encore une fois en mesurant le syndrome
nous projetons ou effondrons effectivement les erreurs en un ensemble discret de possibilités représentées par des produits tensoriels de
matrices de Pauli et en corrigeant ces erreurs c'est-à-dire les erreurs de Pauli nous pouvons récupérer l'état encodé original
entre-temps tout l'aléatoire généré dans le processus est déplacé dans les qubit du syndrome que nous pouvons ensuite
jeter ou réinitialiser ce qui est crucial parce que c'est ainsi que l'entropie générée par les erreurs et les mesures du syndrome est
retirée du système et voilà la fin de la leçon dans laquelle nous avons eu un premier aperçu de la
correction d'erreur quantique y compris le code de Shor à 9 qubit et la discrétisation des erreurs j'espère que tu me rejoindras pour la
prochaine leçon dans laquelle nous allons discuter du formalisme stabilisateur qui nous fournit un outil puissant pour décrire et
analyser une grande et intéressante classe de codes correcteurs d'erreurs quantiques y compris des codes qui sont des candidats prometteurs pour
de vrais ordinateurs quantiques au revoir jusqu'alors